[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on peut apprécier l'économie on peut
aimer l'économie il ne suffit pas
d'aimer pour bien la décrypter
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'on ressent effectivement
une forte augmentation des prix
notamment ce qui est visible c'est
vraiment à la pompe quand on fait le
plein avant bah 60 euros on avait
effectivement de quoi faire 600 700 km
maintenant c'est 90 euros donc il y a
effectivement une réflexion qui s'impose
avant de avant de faire un déplacement
depuis deux mois on a essayé de réduire
deux restos en famille par mois c'est
revenu à 1 parce que oui il faut il faut
bien se servir de la ceinture
je pense que l'état de refaire un petit
effort
c'est déjà apprécié ce qu'il faut le
carburant il devrait voir un peu comment
remédier à ça j'ai vu qu'hier il y avait
une augmentation paradoxale sur RSA les
aides de la famille pourquoi ne pas
basculer également sur le panier de la
ménagère avec ce genre d'herbe
on a besoin dans le temps d'avoir des
éléments de référence on va donc
chercher à composer et à remplir ce
qu'on appelle des indices des
indicateurs des indicateurs qui vont
sélectionner faire un panier un peu le
panier de l'aménagère mais un peu plus
large quand même parce qu'il va être
représentatif et on va essayer de le
composer avec des produits des biens
mais aussi le prix de service et on va
mesurer à travers le temps l'évolution
du prix de ce panier de bien et de
services composé composer un panier de
bien avoir un indice qui va reposer et
qui va donner une indication sur
l'évolution des prix ce n'est pas
quelque chose de nouveau déjà en 1707 un
premier indice synthétique de
l'évolution des prix avait été composée
aujourd'hui désormais on a multitude
d'indices pour n'en citer que
quelques-uns les plus utilisées
peut-être les plus vulgarisées on a bien
sûr l'indice des prix à la consommation
très simplement et abrégé par IPC mais
on a ce même indice harmonisé à des
saints de produire d'autoriser de
permettre de faciliter les comp raison
au sein des membres de l'Union
européenne donc c'est un indice qui dit
harmonisé et quand on regarde les
chiffres on s'aperçoit qu'ils sont un
peu différents parce qu'ils sont
composés de façon un peu différente et
donc on a des mesures qui sont elles
aussi un peu différentes au mois de mai
2022 l'indice était à 5,2 en données je
dirais classique l'IPC l'indice des
prêts à la consommation il était à 5,8
pour l'indice harmonisé on pourrait
aussi citer un indice qui va essayer de
mesurer ce qu'on appelle l'inflation
sous-jacente et là on veut retenir le
plus fort du phénomène c'est à dire
qu'on écarte tous les éléments qui
peuvent faire un peu de bruit qui sont
passagers qui impactent mais qui ne le
font que de façon passagère et on va
mesurer cette inflation sous-jacente
pour essayer de conserver la véritable
tendance de fond inflationniste dans une
économie et là pour la France à la même
période le taux est un peu plus faible
puisqu'on a
3,7%. quand vous entendez parler
d'indices des prix 5% 3%, vous avez
aussi parfois l'impression que vous
concernant
c'est pas la même chose vous avez
l'impression que c'est beaucoup plus et
c'est peut-être le cas des
automobilistes quand on regarde la
décomposition des indices il y a ce
qu'on appelle les postes le poste
énergie dans l'indice des prix il est
pour pas grand chose il est pour moins
de 10%, il a 9 %, ça c'est le poids de
l'énergie dans l'indice mais quand on
regarde les progressions l'énergie a cru
de plus 28%. le ressenti et donc on peut
comprendre qu'il est très fort il est
d'autant plus fort que vous avez un
véhicule je pense que ce ressenti n'est
pas aussi fort pour ceux qui prennent
les transports en commun mais pour
l'automobiliste c'est 28% lui donne une
idée de ce qu'on appelle l'inflation
perçue et qui est là encore un peu en
décalage avec des taux d'inflation tel
qu'on peut les avoir de façon officielle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]